christian bale
congratulations on this film you were
absolutely brilliant thank you how was
it for you watching on the big screen oh
it was wonderful yeah i hadn't seen it
on a big screen and i was watching it
you know with the crowd so it's great to
hear everyone's reactions and what a
film you know taika is a real talent
there were a couple moments where i
actually had to
look away look to the side at how creepy
you were what was the transformation
process like for you how long did it
take um well you know a lot of
conversation ahead of time uh uh tiger
and i you know sort of choosing
inspirations um but also recognizing hey
there's a point that there's there's a
uh excess which uh taika and i wanted to
go and enjoy but was too much you know
we had to kind of pull it in um but
through lots of improvisation and
experimentation with that uh there's a
lot of good stuff that with any film you
know you don't end up seeing in the
final result but then the practical
application was uh we got it down to
three and a half hours uh each morning
but myself and three absolutely
brilliant makeup artists uh creating
gore each and every day the only ones
who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die how perfect gore
now you shaved your head for this film
was there anything else that you did
pre-production to get ready um well i i
was coming just the nature of with the
pandemic and everything that i ended up
i'd verbally committed to different uh
films so i went from
one film straight to
thor um i usually like to have a lot
more time in between but it was
literally like three days between that
and going into quarantine down in
australia um i was already quite skinny
for the film uh that i'd made before so
we looked at the comic book character
who's very muscular
and i said well it just can't happen you
know so we have to look at his
supernatural powers instead and also how
can you come compete with chris in terms
of the muscles you know so no matter how
much i would have
worked out i just would have you know
looked pitiful by comparison let's see
who you are and take off your disguise
and flip
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him then eventually great
so you know we we uh uh uh we figured
all of that out and um and and hit upon
you know this uh which uh uh was uh
a nosferatu and then with a little bit
of uh um well a lot of uh come to daddy
music video by apex twin which tycho and
i both great fans of
the blood in your mouth what was that
um yeah i was asking that because i was
happily just kind of squirting it in my
mouth and we did a lot more scenes where
it was actually spilling out and i was
spitting it everywhere and all that and
uh and then it wasn't until a couple of
weeks later i went wait what is this you
know because i'm swallowing an awful lot
of it but i still don't know exactly
what it was but i was assured it was
safe um but uh yeah black bile the
things that we do for our art right
now i hear there was a lot of improv in
this film were those scenes with you as
well uh yeah we started with three days
of me uh talking non-stop in a monologue
that was probably only you know one
paragraph in the script but then taika
and i just discussed it before so the
other characters couldn't speak i'd my
character had shut them up and i just
went on and on and on um and it was a
great way great introduction to it and
uh my interpretation of it and um none
of it ended up in the final film so i
think that's the uh sort of answer to uh
whether it was any good or not i was
going to say outs like do you like that
mode of operation i do yes yeah i like
it very much you know you get you get
you uh you know you you're here you
understand uh what direction the
director wants to take it in you have
the script and then if you have the
luxury of a bit more time then
absolutely you expand it and see what
happens i was just with natalie and she
was talking about how she says this this
phase that she's in in her career right
now she's just trying to impress her
kids i am like very very um uh into this
obviously for them because they were
just
so happy
to come visit set and they were so
excited to see me wearing a cape and of
course so excited that there's like an
action figure now um so that was really
really um fun to get to be in something
that they were so excited about what
phase are you in in your career would
you say
i look i'm always just stunned that
anybody hires me so i'm constantly in
that phase of my career but it was the
first time that my kids had really paid
an interest in in my choices we always
sit down and make choices together but
this is one where i thought it couldn't
happen and they said they corrected me
on that and said no no dad you're
definitely making this one am i and they
went yes absolutely so i said okay yeah
have they seen the final thing last
night yeah yeah they loved it ah i love
that well next up we're gonna see
another transformation from you in
amsterdam you are reunited with david o
russell you know when you two work
together the oscars come a call in what
is it about you two
that you just make such movie magic we
just bloody enjoy working together and
we got more involved on this one than
ever we actually spent four maybe five
years putting this one amsterdam
together i went off and made different
films and then came back and it's a very
special film and he's a very special
filmmaker
[Music]